überall um uns herum gibt es extrem
negative anzeichen
deswegen ist es jetzt wichtig in
deutschland die weichen zu stellen
wir müssen jetzt in dieser woche
gemeinschaftlich die weichen stellen
sonst besteht die gefahr dass es außer
kontrolle geraten könne
und außer kontrolle geraten heisst
erhebliche folgen für leib und leben zu
riskieren
denn eines ist klar das hat die beratung
jedenfalls uns dort gezeigt dieser
corona wie das des herbst ist nicht
schwächer oder weniger gefährlich als
der korona virus vom märz und april
es sind jetzt bereits ein leichtes
steigen in die krankenhäuser zu
vermelden gott sei dank noch offenen
übrigen niveau aber es gibt auch wieder
erste todesfälle und vor dem hintergrund
braucht es jetzt eine ernsthafte eine
sehr ernsthafte besprechung eine sehr
ernsthafte diskussion
wir wollen keinen zweiten lockdown aber
ein zweiter lockdown rückt dann näher
wenn es keinen druck gibt
wir brauchen jetzt einen ruck in dem wir
uns ehrlich machen in deutschland
entwickeln sich die zahlen sprunghaft
nach oben auch bei uns in bayern
wir liegen zwar im moment in der
relation der inzidenz ian noch etwas
unter der gesamtentwicklung wir sind im
moment auf platz sieben von den
instanzen wenn man das vergleicht bayern
hat im moment zum heutigen tag ein eps
von 27 auf das ganze land umgerechnet
etwas über 27 bremen/berlin deutlich
höher nordrhein westfalen hessen baden
württemberg hamburg leicht überall
wächst es ist keine stilkritik sondern
nur eine beschreibung der situation auch
bei uns in bayern ist die situation so
dass jetzt sechs gebiete über 50 sind
und 14 über 35 das heißt die entwicklung
ist absehbar deswegen mein dringender
appell wir müssen uns jetzt mit dieser
situation national einheitlich
beschäftigen
dabei ist das entscheidende die
infektionszahlen infektionsrate ist die
mutter aller zahlen weil es ihr folgen
alle anderen weiteren zahlen ob
krankenhaus und ähnliches mehr
würden wir jetzt die infektionszahlen
noch ergänzen durch drei vier andere
zahlenwerke kommen wir nicht weiter
warum sage ich das weil es ganz
entscheidend ist dass wir jetzt keine
angst machen keine panik machen aber
dass wir uns einfach ernsthaften
seriöser problematik stellen wir sollen
uns coroner nicht schönreden
wir wollen auch kein selbstbetrug machen
wir soll nicht immer nach schlupflöchern
suchen sondern jetzt überlegen was ist
das beste für ganz deutschland
und deswegen plädiere ich gerade in
dieser woche für einheitlichkeit für
verbindlichkeit und für verständlichkeit
überall in deutschland
wir haben die minister aber sind
konferenz ich glaube wir sollten diesen
versuch jetzt nehmen aus dieser minister
wissen konferenz ein echtes klares
regelwerk für alle in den nächsten
wochen zu machen und zwar unabhängig ob
die zahlen etwas höher oder niedriger
sind denn eines ist klar wenn die zahl
wenn die maßnahmen helfen höhere zahl
nach unten zu bringen
dann helfen sie genauso auch das
niedrige zahl nicht steigen
und wenn sie das anwachsen sind zum
beispiel auch in sachsen und sachsen
jetzt leicht es ist keine ausgenommen
kroner macht an keiner grenze halt weder
in europa noch in deutschland
und deswegen spielen wir im team
vorsicht und umsicht und wollen auch
keinen flickenteppich sondern wollen es
entsprechend schaffen dass wir morgen
eine entsprechende regelung an regelungs
kanon haben denn die bevölkerung
versteht die dann auch motiviert
wirklich sowas und nicht verunsichert
wird ich habe für den donnerstag bereits
zu einer kabinettssitzung eingeladen um
im zweifelsfall am donnerstag dann
entweder maßnahmen der nachzuvollziehen
oder auch diese mpk dann noch einmal zu
bewerten
das ist für uns ist das entscheidende
wir müssen jetzt corona ausbremsen
bevor wir echte notbremsen machen müssen
wir sind bild und wie er liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier und vergesst bitte
nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren